bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 2 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal votre
actualité locale
chaque jour décryptée par les
journalistes de la rédaction mais aussi
nos invités tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
la police se modernise à maurepas plus
de pv papier les policiers municipaux
sont à présent équipés de smartphones
afin de dresser des pv électroniques
pour les infractions de stationnement et
de circulation
le cv vidéo nouvel atout pour décrocher
un entretien et séduire les recruteurs
décryptage avec un atelier organisé à la
maison de l'emploi de saint quentin en
yvelines pour préparer la semaine de
l'emploi
enfin si notre système solaire compter
une nouvelle planète c'est ce qu'annonce
deux chercheurs américains
éléments de réponse avec le latmos dans
notre chronique à suivre et c'est une
petite révolution qu'a connue la police
municipale de maurepas en ce début
d'année filet traditionnel papier laissé
sur le pare brise les pv sont désormais
électronique
les agents de maurepas sont équipés d'un
smartphone avec une application
spécifique une mesure qui concerne
toutes les infractions liées à la
circulation et au statut et au
stationnement pardon comme l'exter tiens
me lambert olivier carol entament leur
journée comme tous les jours mais depuis
quelques semaines leurs habitudes ont
changé
fini les traditionnels carnés vers ils
dégainent leur smartphone place aux pv
électronique avec ce type d'appareil
on a tous dessus on peut verbaliser car
clic type d'infraction
les stationnements com
bonne route pour saturer exécutait la
police municipale de maurepas cette
équipe et de cet appareil comme celui ci
une valeur de 750 euros chacun il
possède une application agréé par l'état
permettant à l'agent de surveillance de
la voie publique de verbaliser les
véhicules en infraction
dresser un pv en une minute au lieu
d'une quinzaine auparavant est
maintenant possible
un gain de temps mais pas seulement a
plus de présence sur le terrain comme ça
la population on va dire général nous
voyais quand même plus longtemps ça a
pas l'air d'une demi heure trois quart
d'heure depuis sur le terrain c'est
quand même important même s'il en
fallait de ma couronne ou autre chose on
est quand même à l'écouté de la
population
on est plus près de nous et un petit peu
plus longtemps
depuis le poste central le chef de la
police municipale veille sur ses
patrouilles
grâce à un système de géolocalisation
inclus dans les appareils
il visualise les agents à proximité d'un
lieu spécifique utile dans le cas d'une
urgence qui permet aussi aux agents de
constater directement sur sur le terrain
des faits qui peuvent se produire on va
on va prendre je sais pas une
dégradation ou ou
éventuellement une branche d'arbre qui
va être au travers de la route ou un
coût qui va être qui va être en
formation donc directement il saisit sur
l'or sur l'un et l'iphone et serpents
spi directement ici au poste de police
municipale et ensuite on saisit les
services compétents
un désir de la nouvelle municipalité de
moderniser son service testé depuis 2009
à paris le pv électronique devrait se
généraliser à toute la france dans les
prochaines années et la 20e semaine de
l'emploi aura lieu du 12 au 19 février à
saint quentin en yvelines afin de
préparer cette semaine
l'agglomération organise différents
ateliers pour répondre aux questions
d'orientation de formation ou encore de
recrutement nous avons suivi l'atelier
sur le cv vidéo une pratique de plus en
plus démocratisé et qui permettrait de
se démarquer face aux recruteurs un
reportage signé à fanny bourdillon adieu
le papier place à la vidéo étudiants et
demandeurs d'emploi se sont rendus à la
maison de l'entreprise pour en savoir
plus sur le cv vidéo un outil de plus en
plus prisée qui intéresse sabrine
étudiant en droit à la recherche d'un
stage on est tous liés aux réseaux
sociaux en tout le monde a une page
facebook dont je me suis dit pourquoi
pas faire quelque chose de concret et
plus professionnelle vis-à-vis du
recruteur et du coup a créé mon propre
cv vidéo dans mon domaine en tout cas
c'est super important d'avoir une image
très professionnelle vu qu'on défend la
cause d'autrui
mais le cv vidéo reste un exercice
difficile qui nécessite une certaine
assurance devant la caméra
francesco a monté sa société de
communication audiovisuelle aujourd'hui
il veut prouver aux participants
l'efficacité du cv vidéo la caméra c'est
un vrai rempart disons qu'il faut
dépasser pour donner le meilleur de soi
c'est mon travail aussi de mettre les
gens à l'aise de travailler mais c'est
un outil qu'est vraiment maîtriser
puisqu'il ya un montage aussi donc en
jeu prend le meilleur de la personne de
meilleur de la prestation
c'est vrai que c'est ça s'adapte plus
aux métiers du tertiaire
disons voilà
que les artisans autres si certains ont
trouvé un emploi grâce au cv vidéo
d'autres cherchent encore un atelier
comment convaincre en deux minutes sera
organisée lundi prochain à la maison de
l'entreprise
car quoi qu'il arrive il faudra toujours
se démarquer devant le recruteur en
entretien et 6,7 intel cet atelier vous
intéresse sachez qu'il reste encore
quelques places
inscriptions sur saint quentin en
yvelines point fr les vacances de
février approchent à grands pas pour les
étudiants cela peut être l'occasion de
travailler et d'ajouter pourquoi pas une
ligne sur leur cv en passant le bafa
pour nous en parler ce soir en plateau
avec nous lors ans cousin directrice
cette ville information jeunesse bonsoir
à vous merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous proposer des sessions de
formation au bafa du 28 février au 6
mars qui vont se dérouler à versailles
pourquoi justement passer le bafa quel
est l'intérêt pour les jeunes de faire
de venir à ces cessions pour un jeune
c'est vrai que ça peut être un premier
premier emploi un emploi saisonnier pour
les étudiants notamment puisqu'ils un
recrutement assez intéressant
d'animateurs pendant les vacances d'été
pendant les vacances scolaires
et puis avec le changement de rythme
scolaire il ya beaucoup de communes qui
sont recherche d'animateurs tout au long
de l'année
alors justement le plafond peut le
passer à partir de 17 ans faut avoir 17
ans le premier jour du stage
comment justement ça se passe qu'elle
soit un petit peu les démarches pour
pouvoir s'inscrire et à passer ce
diplôme alors déjà le bafa en fait ces
trois sessions big at work pour valider
le brevet d'aptitude aux fonctions
d'animateur le premier stage c'est une
c'est un stage d'une semaine qui un
stage théorique
le deuxième stage et un stage pratique
ça veut dire que le jeune doit trouver
une structure d'accueil un centre de
loisirs où un centre de vacances pour
valider ce stage pratique et le
troisième stage est un stage
d'approfondissement qui permet
éventuellement d'accès d'avoir une
spécialisation ça peut être le théâtre
peut être le sport ça peut être de
passer le brevet de secourisme ya
différentes possibilités
alors justement est-ce que à passer son
bafa ça peut aider par la suite pour
16,8 ça peut être un point en plus par
exemple quand on passe des concours pour
les écoles ou flore de choses oui c'est
vrai que c'est le cas mais c'est vrai
que là la première chose effectivement
c'est il faut avoir envie d'être
animateur parce que c'est quand même une
sacrée responsabilité
ces jeunes animateurs vont encadrer et
des mineurs des jeunes donc faut
vraiment avoir envie c'est aussi c'est
beaucoup de temps aussi un consacré
puisqu'il faut monter des projets il
faut encadrer ces jeunes
donc ça mobilise complètement le jeune
faut vraiment déjà la première chose le
premier critère en tout cas c'est
d'avoir envie d'encadrer d'autres jeunes
et les qualités requises érotise un
petit peu pour justement pouvoir devenir
animateur peut-être après directeur de
centre par la suite mais les qualités
c'est effectivement alors déjà j'allais
dire d'avoir un casier ça paraît
peut-être bête ce que je dis mais
d'avoir un casier judiciaire vierge
parce qu'effectivement encore une fois
une réglementation pour l'encadrement de
jeunes mineurs les qualités après basse
et bien sûr des dynamiques d'être force
de proposition c'est des journées bien
remplies comme je le disais donc il faut
aussi avoir beaucoup d'énergie donc faut
être passionné un tout simplement alors
très pratiquement justement si on
s'inscrit donc à cette formation du 28
février au 6 mars on pourra peut-être
travailler dès les prochaines vacances
où vous fera attendre l'été avant les
vacances de pâques
alors c'est vrai qu'on met les sessions
bafa en place pendant les vacances
scolaires puisque c'est le moment où les
jeunes sont disponibles donc il faut
avoir validé ces trois sessions donc
nous on propose le 28 février prochain
une session théorique ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait déjà qu'ils fassent leur 2ème
et 3ème session pour avoir pour être
considéré comme animateur après le stage
pratique c'est déjà une première
expérience professionnelle c'est vrai
qu'on en général elle est rarement
indemniser un nom qui sont plus bénévole
mais ça leur permet de valider le bafa
mais ils peuvent très rapidement si
s'organise bien travaillé pour l'été
prochain pourquoi pas alors sa formation
1 cuil j'imagine tout à fait c'est vrai
qu'il ya sur les trois sessions il y a
deux sessions qui sont payantes alors
nous avec notre partenariat avec la
ville de versailles
on a sur la maison de quartier de près
au bois le prêt de salles qui permet à
l'organisme avec lequel on travaille de
négocier le tarif
donc on propose une session à 270 euros
qui permet justement de lever ce frein
financier pour les jeunes qui
souhaiteraient devenir animateur
est-ce qu'il ya peut-être des aides
financières qui sont proposées aux
jeunes qui souhaiteraient s'inscrire à
fameck a pas les moyens
oui complètement heureusement d'ailleurs
vous pouvez trouver toutes ces
informations sur un dossier qu on
réactualise tous les ans dossier bafa
que vous trouvez sur notre site internet
où là on explique justement tout tout
tout tout les modalités alors vous avez
la casse principalement qui propose une
aide financière et le conseil
départemental et puis après il ya des
communes aussi qui s'investissent et qui
propose des bourses au bafa pour pour
leurs jeunes pendant qu'il faut se
renseigner alors une fois qu'on obtient
le bafa comment ça se déroule après ce
qu'on va du coup peut-être à la mairie
de sa commune pour intégrer un centre de
loisirs commencent à fonctionner un
petit peu oui tout à fait l'idée c'est
effectivement de déjà à proximité sur
les structures que l'on peut avoir
fréquenté soi même d'aller les voir et
de proposer ses services
et puis après il ya des sites internet
un con mais aussi dans ce guide qui sont
des bourses à l'emploi dans le domaine
de l'animation qui permet de voir les
structures qui recherche des animateurs
s'il ya des choses qui ont évolué il ya
beaucoup de pas mal d'années maintenant
c'est vraiment sur internet que se font
aussi les démarches
oui alors pour les jeunes qui seraient
intéressés par notre prochaine session
il faut savoir qu'effectivement il ya
une inscription obligatoire un numéro
qui leur sera demandé il faut qu'ils
aillent sur le site jeunes pointent
gouv.fr et là ils vont selon la région
cliquez sur leur région et avoir une
démarche industrie administrative à
faire en fait leur dossier voilà
dématérialisée et les trois sessions
donc tous les commentaires seront en
ligne est validée en ligne donc là on
parle de du bafa en tant que déjà dédé
mais après ça que déboucher également
sur autre chose directeur de centre ça
voilà ces carrières possibles comment ça
se passe justement après alors c'est
vrai que le bea est vide et la
différence c'est qu'effectivement
dirige un centre de vacances ou centres
de loisirs
après juste une petite précision c'est
vrai que le bafana pas n'est pas un
diplôme professionnel même si
effectivement on peut travailler avec le
bafa après il ya des filières jeunesse
et sport qui sont adaptés à quelqu'un
qui voudrait se professionnaliser dans
ce secteur d'activité la notamment le
bpjeps par exemple donc je le rappelle
il reste donc des places disponibles
pour la session du 28 février au 6 mars
après les faits ça se passe à versailles
vous retrouvez toutes les informations
donc donc dans les locaux d'une
information jeunesse qui sont à montigny
le bretonneux ou sur le site internet il
va s'afficher en bas de votre écran
www.id grec itgi 70,2 points org numéro
de téléphone aussi également affiché
n'hésitez pas à prendre ces informations
il reste une vingtaine de places est
justement pour pouvoir en profiter
merci beaucoup à laurent ce cousin
d'avoir répondu à nos questions tout
autre sujet à présent devons parler de
la pmi de magny les hameaux elle
pourrait fermer une décision qui
viendrait du conseil départemental même
si à ce jour aucune information
officielle n'a été publiée sur un
quelconque échéancier concernant ce
souhait de fermeture du service de la
pmi
le maire de magny les hameaux a fait
part de son opposition quant à cette
décision via un communiqué il a émis la
volonté d'obtenir un rendez-vous urgent
avec pierre bédier président du conseil
départemental en présence des
conseillers départementaux du canton de
maurepas il est soutenu dans sa
mobilisation par aurore bergé chef de
file de l'opposition de la commune mais
aussi yves vandewalle conseiller
régional et alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux également vice
présidente du conseil départemental des
yvelines via également un communiqué ils
ont souhaité que la décision relative à
la fermeture de la pmi soit reconsidéré
et cette fermeture devait être
malheureusement confirmée il serait
essentiel qu'elle soit compensée au plus
tôt par la mise en place d'unités
mobiles pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture dans l'accès aux services
publics
une pétition concernant justement la
fermeture de la pmi de magny les hameaux
a été mise en ligne sur challenge un.org
parlons maintenant santé est la mise les
médecine thérapeutique orientale sont de
plus en plus utilisés en occident de nos
jours à l'exemple du shiatsu
cette technique de thérapie manuelle
d'origine japonaise inspiré du massage
chinois à saint cyr l'école monique le
pizou et praticiens professionnels de
shiatsu
elle nous a ouvert
les portes de son cabinet ou via mail
pour ce reportage
le shiatsu c'est une technique de
massage japonais
donc c'est un massage on travaille avec
les pousse les paumés les coudes on fait
des pressions sur tout le corps et s'est
basé sur l'acupuncture donc c'est en
résumé un genre de digitopuncture on
travaille avec le poids du corps et la
respiration équilibrer les énergies de
son corps avec le shiatsu cette méthode
de massage thérapeutique basée sur le
yin et le yang fonctionne sur un système
simple du donneur et du receveur
le shiatsu est avant tout un partage il
ya 365 points en acupuncture
donc en fait ces points ils suivent ne
cire des circuits d'énergie qu'on
appelle des méridiens je travaille delà
de la tête jusqu'à leur taille
l'intérêt du shiatsu c'est que c'est une
technique globale un travail global
donc moi je parle pas de technique je
fais un taux d'un art parce que la façon
de faire la pression c'est ce qui fait
la différence entre un praticien et un
autre pour son shiatsu monique travail
avec le poids du corps la respiration et
sur table chaque praticien exerce selon
son enseignement
je viens rechercher un petit peu
d'énergie de dynamisme et c'est ce que
me donne les séances de shiatsu pendant
voilà pendant quelques quelques temps
quelques mois et j'essaie de vue de
faire deux séances à l'année voilà pour
me rebooster un petit peu utilisé
généralement en tant que médecine
préventive en 2015 cette discipline a
reçu une reconnaissance professionnelle
du titre de spécialiste en chine à deux
sous au répertoire national des
certifications professionnelles et si le
shiatsu vous a plu je vous propose
maintenant de découvrir le chi cong
cette gymnastique traditionnelle
chinoise fondée sur la maîtrise de
l'énergie vitale une méthode destinée à
la santé mais aussi au bien-être du
corps williams elle encore lui a assisté
à une des séances de formation à cette
technique
améliorer sa santé son bien-être
intérieur en faisant corps avec la terre
le chi kong littéralement exercice de
maîtrise de l'énergie vitale est une
méthode chinoise qui regroupe des
techniques de gymnastique méditation et
de respiration à saint cyr l'école
monique pidio transmet son savoir faire
chaque semaine
le chi comme c'est le travail de
l'énergie par les mouvements donc on
stimule le système énergétique du corps
en faisant des mouvements avec les bras
les jambes on se reconnecte avec son
corps pour atteindre l'état de chicons
qu'un travail d'installation est
nécessaire un travail qui passe par
cette gymnastique physique jusqu'à
l'harmonie totale des mouvements du
corps et de l'esprit avec la terre quand
on voit un arbre c'est vraiment l'image
du tic ont l'arbre il est enraciné donc
à les racines et il a les feuilles qui
partent ces branches qui partent vers le
ciel et nous on fait partie de la nature
donc on est comme un arbre donc il faut
qu'on recrée ses racines donc le
ressenti des racines se fait par le
relâchement du poids du corps
monique parle de plusieurs types de chi
kong celui du singe ou de l'éléphant une
technique très symbolique qui aident à
la représentation du corps dans l'esprit
chaque chi kong ayant un effet
particulier moi je me sens
particulièrement bien détendu zhenghua
bien prendre conscience de son corps de
son énergie et puis après ben oui assez
un bien-être très agréable une méthode
qui se décline en plusieurs variantes
petit doit être pratiquée régulièrement
pour être bien maîtrisé pour monique le
chi kong plus qu une gymnastique du
corps est un art de vie
en 2006 l'assemblée générale de l'union
astronomique internationale déclassé
pluton en planète naine notre système
solaire repas c'est donc à seulement
huit planètes mais le 20 janvier dernier
dell de la nouveauté de chercheurs
américains faisait une annonce il y
aurait une planète
au delà de neptune et même de pluton
elle serait la neuvième planète de notre
système solaire pour nous en parler en
plateau avec nous ce soir mélanie potier
bonsoir mélanie st sour floral alors il
faut d'abord apporter une précision ce
n'est pas une découverte à proprement
parler cette fameuse planète n'a pas
encore été observée mais l'étude
présentée le 20 janvier par mike brown
et constantine backing deux chercheurs
du caltech le california institute of
technology est une grande avancée
son existence n'est donc pas encore
réellement prouvé mais des éléments ont
mis la puce à l'oreille des deux
scientifiques
ce sont les perturbations sur les
orbites de certains objets notamment les
planètes naines qui ont amené les
scientifiques à l'envisager apurva aux
as et étudiant en deuxième année de
thèse au latmos le laboratoire
atmosphères observations spatiales de
huy en cours il vient des états unis il
est spécialisé dans les exoplanètes et
nous explique sur quoi les scientifiques
basent leurs idées pour dire un peu de
contexte et autres objets il fait partie
d'une ceinture des qui perd et ça c'est
après un acte une donc plutôt fait
partie de cette ceinture il y a un sur
15000 chances qu'un toutes ces objets
qui sont concentrées 1 de notre parti
dans un système solaire c'est par hasard
donc si ça c'est un sur 15000 c'est un
très très probable qu'il ya un autre
planète qui qui équilibre ses autres
objets alors même si j'ai bien compris
c'est seulement une chance sur 15000 qui
nous laisse penser qui laisse penser aux
chercheurs qui existerait une autre
planète
une chance sur 15000 monde va le voir
sur l'écran ça sera plus que plus facile
à comprendre
ce sont surtout toutes ces orbites qui
sont très ressemblantes qui ont amené
les scientifiques à penser qu'il existe
une autre planète
elle serait à une distance représentant
200 fois celle entre la terre et le
soleil ou encore 30 milliards de
kilomètres cette rue
est très loin son orbite pour l emmener
donc très loin du soleil mais elle
serait toujours dans notre système
solaire alors qu'elles soient solides ou
gazeuse qu'elle ressemble à neptune ou
comme à la terre s'est encore inconnu
par contre c'est sa taille qui est
encore aujourd'hui très envisager la
planète lui-même et les parts du tube
morizet séquelles des orbites à mai dans
les modèles pour avoir un planète qui
est cette partie là avec les autres
objets de ceinture du keeper il doit
être très massif et très massif pour moi
c'est plus que 10 fois masse terrestre
alors que 10 de solides on s'est quand
même pas beaucoup on a beaucoup utilisé
le conditionnel dans cette chronique
mélanie mais qu'est ce qu'elle va
apporter une telle découverte à une
telle découverte ça pourrait dire que le
système solaire est plus grand que ce
qu'on imagine ça permettrait aussi de
lancer de nouveaux programmes
d'observation quitte à la découvrir
définitivement comme dans toutes les
recherches ça peut prendre des dizaines
d'années vous l'aurez compris florane on
est encore qu'aux balbutiements de
l'histoire de cette neuvième planète
l'univers nous réserve chaque jour des
surprises les chercheurs conduits
continue donc à chercher
histoire à suivre je viens de suivre
l'actualité de l'espace et de l'univers
avec vous mais annie merci beaucoup
autre sujet à présent ce dimanche la
ferme du manet à montigny le bretonneux
accueilli le concert symphonique du
conservatoire de musique de la commune
la deuxième partie était réservée à
l'orchestré symphonique avec une
cinquantaine de musiciens
la première partie a permis aux
différents élèves du conservatoire comme
vous le voyez à l'image de montrer leur
talent au public une première pour
plusieurs d'entre eux qui avaient le
trac comme habituelle elle me dit qu'il
a recueilli leurs impressions
c'est un travail important de
préparation à la fois en cours
individuels d'instruments et bien
évidemment en répétition alors on a des
répétitions un peu particulière pour
cette session symphonique qui est un peu
comme un stage ça fait une semaine que
les élèves répètent pour préparer cette
session symphonique ce programme
symphonique et alors que les futurs
bacheliers ont commencé à remplir leurs
voeux pour les administrés les
admissions postbac et les établissements
y viennois ouvrent leurs portes pour
mieux les guider dans leur future
formation ce week-end c'était le cas de
l'école nationale supérieure du paysage
à versailles
école qui possède 9 hectares de jardins
fruitiers et de potagers historique
forme environ 130 diplômés les
précisions au micro de camille lambert
alors l'entrée à l'école se fait sur
concours à bac +2 ou +3 un peu importe
mais c'est un minimum de bac + 2 c'est
un concours de des preuves à la fois
d'arts plastiques d'écriture d'analystes
du paysage les journées portes ouvertes
c'est toujours un moment important pour
une école c'est l'occasion de montrer
évidemment ce que font ce que font les
élèves d'accueillir peut-être les futurs
élèves mais également de faire revenir
des anciens élèves
on peut facilement aller vers eux et
voilà et discuter de leurs envies d'où
ils viennent
pourquoi il aurait rendu car ça et on
donne si notre notre regard sur les
années qu'on a passées à l'école et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis demain édition
spéciale du journal du mercredi 3
février le préfet des yvelines serge
morvan sera en direct avec nous nous
parlerons de son parcours lui qui occupe
ce poste pour la première fois de sa
carrière depuis l'été dernier il sera
question également de la prolongation de
l'état d'urgence et plus globalement des
répercussions de l'action du
gouvernement dans le département serge
morvan qui réagira également au projet
de fusion des départements des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine ne manquez pas
cette édition tout de suite vous avez
rendez vous avec nicolas qui est le vide
pour le 7-8 société objet du débat la
fin des 35 heures en question quant à
moi je me retrouve demain avec wilfrid
errishi pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée